hey guys confess here I'm going to
you the basics of a move called
turntable which is a transition you can
use in many different ways in AcroYoga
and this is one of the few moves in a
CRO that led to injuries on my part
several times in the shoulders and the
elbows you shouldn't get hurt
consistently doing acro and if you're
getting consistently heard doing a
single move you're probably doing it
incorrectly
or there might be a smarter way so what
I'm going to show you is what worked for
me it took me probably a year to figure
out how to do this it's embarrassing to
admit but it's true and these are
different tidbits borrowing from a lot
of people who are better than I am I'm
not inventing any of this stuff but I'll
show you what worked for me as I've had
elbow surgery on this side
reconstructive surgery on this shoulder
so I had to compensate in a lot of ways
and I can do this with people up to
about my body weight now at this point
all right so we have kiplyn tada capelin
at kiplyn on all the socials ki plin n
kickin sag miller and we're going to
start in something called full belief
very relaxed position then we're going
to go to something called reverse back
and then I will walk you through how
this works alright
so in this case of course I am basing
she is flying and we're just going to go
straight into old leaf boom very relaxed
position now from here she's going to
effectively dive through my legs I'm
opening my legs to push her through as
far as possible and then close my legs
behind so it holds her in this position
this makes my job a lot easier she's
holding on to her ankles or feet in
butter connives as I call it a buttock
on a sauna now from here what am I going
to do well you want to use bone stacking
as much as possible you want to use your
muscles as little as possible so from
here what I'm going to do is put one
hand pretty much directly in between her
shoulder blades and then the other arm
is going to be either right at the
sacrum okay right about here or it can
be a little bit to the side that can be
very helpful if you're dealing is
heavier than you are so not just
centered but a little bit to the side on
the side that you're going to remove
your foot now this is this is where I'm
going to change something so instead of
having this arm straight this is how I
injured myself
to start with you can you can then
evolve your technique to be straight I'm
going to drop this elbow sort of into my
gut so that I'm using my torso to
support it and not the doing a front
raise or someone's body then I'm going
to as soon as I take this foot off hook
the shin underneath okay from here as I
rotate her I'm going to lift this shin
up to get my arms straight and then
replace the foot place the foot and here
we are okay
arms straight now if I want to continue
this motion okay I can just replace the
hand so we're in basically a mirror
position always three points of contact
so I removed this I have two hands one
foot as soon as I remove this foot this
foot replaces it this one kind of loops
around boom back to the hip and we are
right where we started and then I can
pop kiplyn out and we can go to Byrd we
can do whatever we want to do what you
do all sorts of craziness from here
depending on if we're doing acrobatics
or doing therapeutics but for now that
is a turntable thanks for watching guys
I hope you enjoyed it and if you want to
see more I have some fantastic stuff
coming including collaborations just
click here and you'll be the first to
see it